what does the director say to an actor
after yells cut okay I'll tell you what
I think they should say but it's a good
question because very often too often
they say nothing to the actor they'll
just they'll go on to talk to the
cameramen they'll talk to sound oh
that's appropriate but somehow the actor
is ignored or they'll say okay fine fine
we're moving on my thing is the first
thing you say to an actor after every
take after every even after every
rehearsal is always say thank you very
good acknowledge the work my contention
is that an actor is always doing the
best they can with the information they
have just acknowledge that even if it's
not what you want even if you don't like
it say thank you very good acknowledge
the effort because the reason for this
is a directors one of the directors
primary jobs working with actors and
this is a not a difficult one to do but
a lot of directors don't do it is to
create a really safe place a safe place
is a an environment that has literally
no criticism any director who criticizes
an actor for performance is shooting
themselves in the foot because as soon
as an actor is criticized they start to
shut down inside and you want their
emotional system and their life
experience to be available to you and
you are going to criticize them it's not
going to happen they will keep acting
and that's what you'll get is acting you
won't get good authentic performances to
create that safe place one of there are
many ways but one of them is constantly
acknowledge them and constantly praise
them to say thank you very good that's
all has to be nothing more than that
and then they will stay open and then
they will stay available to you and then
there are a lot of ways which I get into
another time is even if you don't like
what you're seeing how you can make an
adjustment one way is the interrogation
I can say thank you very good start
interrogating the characters and send
them in again and then the performances
will change I'll get what I want so
there's a way to be constructive without
criticizing there's a way to you say
interrogate without can you give me an
example of what a criticism
be on set and how that actor would shut
down okay I'm you set up a scene you've
rehearsed the scene you did your first
take let's say this with the two of you
I'm doing the scene we did our first
take and my reaction was oh damn
okay now that oh no that's okay we got
to do this again
that didn't work right and right then
how do you feel horrible right yeah like
not I haven't pleased the director it's
not what he wanted I'm not a good enough
actress he's probably saying wonder why
he hired me l all of these things now
that that was a criticism not a harsh
criticism I mean it gets a lot harsher
yeah but that wasn't harsh but those
things happen all the time or you do the
scene I'm doing a close-up on you and
you're doing that okay no no no no no
that's not what I meant
here's what I mean you get you know and
then I start to give you more results I
even give you a line reading and what's
going to happen inside you you are dying
or you're angry or are you resentful in
other words on now I am stimulating
inside you all the emotions I don't need
I don't need any of those you know my
job is to stimulate inside you the
emotions I do need for you for the
character that's why I say direct the
character so any criticism or adjustment
that sounds like it's critical or that
the when the director is disappointed in
the performance is damaging it's always
damaging so taking that same scenario
and let's suppose it wasn't your liking
it's not what you need how would you do
it where it was more of an interrogation
and it was more positive reinforcement
okay let's say you did a take I didn't
like it at all okay I did a close up in
you and I'm going that's not what I want
at all I would say thank you thank you
very very very good okay we're going to
go again and then right at that moment
I'll start interrogating your character
and I'll start asking your character
questions and what will happen for you
Karen is your mind your actor mind will
go away your actor mind hood
thank you very good we're going to go
again that's what you know now I'm now
the character brain is totally activated
and now you're just totally in the and
you're not thinking about the last take
not I can get the last take out of your
head I can get all that and I've got you
back into the character I'll make and
through these questions I can adjust
your emotional state of mind within 30
seconds and and say okay roll let's go
again and now you're going again and
you're going again you're going to do
the same scene one thing you do not have
in your head which is good is how are
you going to do this scene you have no
idea you just know that now you feel a
little more resentful let's say I did
that you feel more resentful of the your
scene partner and you're going into the
scene and I say just go in the scene and
you know what you get to do just do the
scene the best you can do you know what
it'll change it'll be different and
because there's no plan from you or me
it will be authentic and you may even
come out and you may even afterwards go
home that came out different I go yeah
it's great okay let's do another one yet
each one will be authentic because the
authenticity the lack of authenticity is
because of the plan you and I can't be
authentic even in this moment if we had
a plan right now we're just in a
conversation that's authentic
you